It's really a pleasure to be here and
talking about something that was one of my
passions,
uh,
in recent years and something that I've
really come to enjoy the full process
of. And that's something
that I wanted to share. Um,
I struggled a bit in trying to come up
with exactly how I wanted to frame this
talk,
whether or not I should go into kind of
the nitty nitty gritty details or give a
more full blown look at everything
that might go into this. And uh,
I decided I'd go into the,
uh,
inch deep mile wide type of approach and
cover all of the different things that
people might enjoy.
Uh,
my goal at the end of this is to show you
all of the different complexities that
go into running a game as well as
hopefully convince a couple of view to
possibly try it out. So, uh, with that,
I just want to cover a little bit of my
background as far as how it helps out,
uh, in discussion. Let's
talk, uh, like many folks,
I grew up playing video games
all through my childhood.
It was something that was
a great activity for me.
I've formed bonds with all sorts of games
and really enjoyed just playing and,
and learning the lessons that
they had for me. But beyond that,
it was an activity.
It was something that I enjoyed it.
It was not something that I
had intended to turn into,
kind of a lifelong passion.
Um,
my first foray into more competitive
focus gaming occurred, uh,
in my teenage years.
I was,
became part of the Super Smash Brothers
Melee competitive community in the mid
two thousands.
And that was,
that was transformational for me
is something where I was good,
I was not great, but it was something
that let me travel to tournaments.
I could do a meet up
with all sorts of people,
get different perspectives on that.
And really some of my best
memories are part of that. But, uh,
back on the real life side of things, uh,
I went through and started my schooling,
um,
went through,
got masters degrees in
computer engineering and cyber
operations as far as how
that applies to the talk.
Uh, it really is just my,
my note though of I have
a formal background in
engineering software development
as well as reverse engineering and,
uh,
let's say knowing how to
treat software creatively, uh,
to try and get certain things
out of it. Uh, and I'm very, uh,
fortunate to be able to continue that
in my professional work with MIT. Um,
but really what we're here to talk
about today is the speed earning side of
things. And this is something
that I started up because I,
I missed out on all of this,
uh,
kind of competitive aspects that I had
to drop when I started school of, um,
super smash brothers.
But I also had this deep nostalgia for
all these games that I played as a kid.
And speed running was my way to
actually dive into that. And, um,
over the course of the last 10
years or so, I've speed run,
I've completed speed runs of more than
two dozen different games and most of
which from scratch. So I'm hoping to kind
of share some of those lessons today,
uh, as we go through more
of the talk. But, uh,
that's the main thing we're talking about
today is of course video games and um,
we'll differentiate that online.
Um,
usually by just putting it as one word
instead of two to differentiate it from
athletic running. But when we're talking
about here is completing a game quickly.
Um,
the duration of this usually goes from
the time that you press start until the
time the credits roll.
And what I'm going to be talking about
today is all things performed by hand.
All things that are done
without tool assistants.
There are other types of speed runs that
are performed with tool assistance. Uh,
and there's,
they're really interesting,
they have a whole bunch of
other different things to them.
But for the lessons that I'm going
to be talking about today, uh,
we're going to be just focusing
on the human element to things.
Some other important lingo, uh, as
we go through this is category a.
And when a speed runner or anybody
else talks about a category, uh,
there are really talking
about the rule sets,
the restrictions and the goals that
they're trying to perform this run under.
Um, and this is really important because
it will differentiate something, um,
a speed run done with no restrictions
versus one that's done towards complete
item collection or restricting different,
uh,
techniques that you might be able to use.
So that's what it is.
Why would you want to do it? What a lot
of people see is the competitive aspect.
Uh, it's something that,
uh, if you get good enough,
you can claim that you are the
best in the world at something.
And that's certainly a worth
of bragging rights. Uh,
there's a real sense of
accomplishment that comes from that.
But I would say that that's actually
kind of in the minority of primary
motivations and why you'd
want to get involved. Um,
what's a much bigger piece of
that is actually diving into,
uh, the community side
of speed runs. So, um,
one of the things that is really good
for newcomers is that as you come in, um,
there's all sorts of people
who will be supporting you,
who will be commenting on you,
um,
enjoying your own progress as you go
through and try to challenge yourself,
reach new goals,
and really test your own limits.
And that's kind of the
most fulfilling part. Um,
and a lot of people are drawn to that.
They don't necessarily need
to be the best in the world,
but they really want something that will
let them play the games that they love
and enjoy it in a brand new way. And
that's what speed runs help to accomplish.
But why would you choose speed
as a particular challenge?
Why not score or some other difficult
type of challenge in the game? Well,
that's where things get a little technical
speed is important because it has a
number of different trade
offs that really, uh,
they increased the difficulty of
performing at a, at the human level. And,
uh, one of the examples that I have
for this on the chart on the left,
this is just a quick graph
showing the time taken, uh,
to travel one mile as
you increment speeds.
And the thing to note here is
that as you're going forward,
you're actually encountering
diminishing returns.
So for each additional unit of speed,
let's say that it took the same
amount of effort to increase,
to increase one unit of speed.
As it goes,
you're actually getting less and less
benefit. The further along it goes.
And that's really important
when you're trying to,
let's say save a small fractions of a
second because that means that for every
new small amount of time
that you're shaving off,
that's a huge amount more effort
in order to get to that next step.
The other side of things,
if you treat the game as just a black
box and you're sending inputs to it,
uh,
to try and achieve some optimal goal,
some a state within the game that is
going to tell you you've succeeded. Uh,
this is a classic state explosion problem.
Um,
even in a game that only responds to two
different inputs, you have a case of, uh,
just even for one second of Gameplay,
you're looking at a 120 bits of possible
paths to search through and try and get
that that's on par with some of the
cryptographic a block ciphers that we have
today.
And that's just not happening.
But of course you can cut that down.
Use intuition to ha to try and limit the
number of paths that you need to search.
But at this point it's not
even really playing the game.
This is trying to treat it
as an optimization problem.
And this is actually a really important
point that I want to draw some more
attention to.
So we're going to take a slight break
and go into something a little different.
Let's talk about art.
So this is a particular image from artists
[inaudible] and I am just about the
last person that you want talking
anything about art and characteristics,
but it seems perfectly competent.
It's pretty, uh, it's, and some,
a piece of art and an East Asian
style seems fine. I'd have,
I'd be happy to have this up in my home.
Um,
the caveat on this particular piece of
art is that it was created in Microsoft
Excel.
Um,
and this is just about the last thing
that people would expect to use from
Microsoft for Microsoft Excel.
This is a program built up entirely
around data tabulation and organization.
And you have,
uh,
Mr [inaudible] here is using it to set
up all sorts of things to create this
fantastic picture.
And this just goes to show that just
because excel was created to work with
numbers, it doesn't mean you can't do
other things with it. Um, and in fact,
it has all the functionality that you
can needs there to create something like
that. Um, and he's not the only one.
There's hundreds of other people who
will do art in excel just because it has
the tools available and it's something
that they can easily get to and work
with. Um, might not be as powerful
as illustrator or something else, uh,
meant for that purpose.
But it is effective and it's still lets
people reach their creative expression
and create the products that they want.
So what about speed runs?
What, um, what a lot of people,
uh, casual observers and,
and other people who
are watching speed runs,
a lot of their first impressions are,
that's not how I played the game. That's,
that's not what the developer
intended for the game.
And in a lot of ways the right, uh,
that doesn't really matter though.
The goal here is to create an
optimized solution through the game.
The game itself,
the narrative,
all of the different elements that the
developers put into it to try and make an
experience don't matter as much.
Um,
it's still the game, but they're more
concerned with this is the world.
These are the rules that I need to
work within to try and reach my end
destination.
And that's really what's going on here.
But if the speed runners aren't bounded
by the rules set by the developers,
what are they bounded by?
And this is where we go into a lot of
other topics dealing with how speed run
should be organized.
What constitutes a valid speed run?
How do you make things
comparable? Um, for example,
even the timing methodology is something
that varies pretty significantly by the
different games. Um, some
of the major timing, um,
methodologies that are listed
on the right side vaguely.
But the main thing is that
what you're measuring,
even though you're
getting a metric of time,
what you're measuring is actually
the skill of your performance.
And it's always important to keep that
in mind as you're trying to set up these
different qualifications
on what's happening.
And as you look through
some of these other topics,
really what we're doing is this
is all experimental design.
You want to create something
that is comparable between
different people forming
under the same set of goals
and restrictions so that
you can determine is this
from better,
is that run better?
What is the skill that they
use to accomplish this?
And that's largely what happens with
speed or an organization, but that's,
that's just the highest level a look at
kind of how speedruns or formed talking
about everything that a speed run is.
From here on,
I really want to talk about
how to do a speed run.
And that's kind of where
the meat of things is. Um,
and really the most interesting parts,
the general process that I devised and,
and really espouse in this is going
through a three, three phase approach. Uh,
you start out with investigation where
you're trying to understand what,
what is the game that I'm working with?
What are its limits? What can I do? Um,
you take that knowledge and you apply it.
Once you get to routing,
where you actually make the decisions
you want to come up with, here's my path.
Uh, these are the set of decisions that
I'm going to respond to and really, uh,
what I believe to actually make an
optimal solution going through this game.
And then finally you get to execution
because just having a theory about what's
a fastest isn't good enough, you need
to actually put it through the end,
make your best attempt to reproduce
that particular route and then go from
there. This is not a waterfall
style approach though. Um,
there's all manner of things that you
might find and you're going to wind up
going back to earlier parts just so that
you either increase your understanding,
make some different decisions
when something doesn't
work out right and really
still,
um,
at the end you're always getting
to this point of doing the run.
And that's kind of the important piece.
So what I'm going to go through here is
just some of the major topics in each of
these as we go through.
So investigation,
a lot of people will skip
over investigation or they
won't give it the proper
credit, uh, do just because
it's not the most glamorous. Um,
really what you're trying
to do is catalog data.
You're trying to build up your own
knowledge pool as you're going through and
making sure that you actually document
it correctly. I want to get into notes,
making sure it's communicated out so
other people can follow the same thing.
But this is basically the entire phase
where your understanding of the game and
that understanding is really what
you're going to be exploiting as you go
through each individual step.
But for understanding,
you really have to first understand,
um, what else is out there. And,
um, the very first thing that you should
do is just go out there and find what is
known. Uh, this might be
kind of an obvious step,
but really the depth that you go through,
this is
kind of surprising to a lot of people.
Uh,
obviously you start with seeing if
there's other speed runs and I'm not just
talking about speed run videos. Uh,
find out if there's other comments,
other posts.
I the thing that's actually indicative
of the thought process that a person went
through in planning a speed run,
it's all very important because you'll
be able to work with that and go from
there.
Um,
the second level where you're still going
to find a lot of useful information is
just the general, um, guides
for a particular game.
So the players guides anything
online, game guide, related, uh,
different fan franchise, uh, sites.
We'll have a lot of useful information
that other fans of cataloged,
maybe not for the purpose of the
speed run, but it's data to you.
So you're going to take
it in all the same. Um,
where a lot of people miss out is
actually in these, these tier three, uh,
types of resources.
And the way that I've set up the tears
is just the likelihood that you're going
to find useful information.
But in the same way you might find some
of the most interesting stuff when you
start to really stretch the
limits of what you're looking at.
So finding any other
related gameplay videos,
there's actually a lot of times then
that people are doing a let's play and
they'll do something weird and like,
oh,
I didn't know that would happen and a
speed run. We'll come along. And like,
I can use that. And it's really important
to kind of go through that steps. Um,
but international sites is
also something that, uh,
really doesn't occur to a lot of people.
In some of my own research,
I was working on a game called
front mission gun hazard
and it's a Japanese only
game. So, of course, most of the resources
that are going to be in Japanese on,
on the other side of the Internet that,
uh,
I don't go to very often because
I can't read it very well,
but I'm in actually doing the do,
do effort and going over there,
uh,
I was able to find a loan page on
some fan sites squirreled away that a
particular glitch.
Um,
and it had enough details in there
that I was able to figure it out and
reproduce it.
And that actually ended up getting used
in a speed run to pretty good effect.
So that was,
that was my story about a really going
the extra mile and trying to investigate
that. But this is all about
everything that is known.
What do you do for the
things that aren't known?
And for that we go back to our
good old friend scientific method.
One of the biggest things that is really
exciting about this part is the raw
discovery of what it is
that you're looking at.
So just imagine that all of physics,
the,
everything that we knew about
physics was wiped clean.
Like you could still tell
that when you throw a ball,
it's going to follow some sort of arc,
but you don't know the mechanics
behind it. You don't know, uh,
let's say what the constant of
gravity is or anything else like that.
That's something that you do every time
that you step into a new video game and
you're really trying to figure
out how do these things interact.
What are the rules that govern how
they actually work? And for that,
the scientific method is
perfect for actually going
through and figuring out the
individual things.
And for many of us,
this is something that we don't get the
chance to use in our daily lives. Um,
it something that they taught to us in
middle school and we knew it enough to
pass the test. But, uh,
getting an actual opportunity to
exercise it is something that, uh,
for everybody I've talked to is to try
to experience this is really rewarding
when you actually come through
and you figure out, wow,
that particular formula works this way.
Or I didn't know I could
influence it with um,
trying to just run up and kick
a wall or something like that.
And really you just follow the same
steps of identifying what it is that you
actually want to know. Developing
hypothesis, setting up an experiment,
and then ultimately trying to analyze
the results of that experiment and decide
how it actually impacts things.
And that's how you build up all of the
knowledge that isn't already known and
written down elsewhere.
But this has helped a little bit simply
because you're living in a land of
software, which means that everything in
that world is going to be bounded by the
restraints of software.
And really everything is governed by
some amount of math and that's really
everything. Um, for a
lot of casual players,
they don't realize that let's say the
power upstate of Mario and Super Mario
world is actually governed by a single
address that is responding to whatever
that value is. All right,
that's interesting to know,
but why would I care about
that as a speed rider? Well,
it just so happens that that
particular value goes into a,
an index into a big table that you might
be able to do some funny things with
and you get some fantastic results just
as long as you know, uh, the math and,
and fundamentals behind
that. Uh, beyond that,
some of the other things that you kind
of take for granted are still governed by
different calculations. For
example, a typical hit box scenario,
and this is basically when two objects
deciding whether they're colliding or not,
is simply whether two squares are
overlapping on a Cartesian, ma'am,
something relatively simple
to do and implement. Uh,
but it's not immediately apparent simply
because of all of the artistic work on
top of the game that's going on.
And then of course,
there's also just the regular formulas
of the final fantasy five sore damage
formula illustrated there at the bottom.
And the important part is knowing all
of the different pieces that go into it.
But as a speed runner,
you will absolutely need to know what all
of those different factors are and how
best you can optimize it so that you
wind up with a enough damage to take out
that boss and a certain number of turns.
And that's the kind of thing that
you're going to try and look for.
The last thing in investigation,
and this is probably the most fun
for a lot of people, is discovery.
So once you start to know
what those limits are,
you can really start to push them and
find out other ways to use and abuse the
game beyond what anybody really expected.
Um,
this covers everything from using basic,
uh,
basic aspects of the game.
For example, in mega man,
for if you take damage from an enemy,
you have a brief period of
vulnerability afterwards. Well,
you can abuse that brief
period and vulnerability and
interact with things that
would otherwise instantly kill you
for as long as you're in vulnerable.
So you can use that to your advantage
and skip through some things that, uh,
would otherwise not be.
Uh, very polite. Um,
there's also instances where if you're
know the fundamentals of how the game is
actually operating a,
in this case,
the random number generation
sequence of a game,
you might be able to actually exploit
that so you can make what would be a lucky
occurrence into a consistent occurrence.
And that's something that we're getting
a much more exposure to recently as
people really dive into what makes the
games tick and seeing just how much a
human can interact and influence.
The last thing that I want
to discuss here is, uh,
actually illustrated by that
picture on the right side.
And I really love this picture.
This is from a glitch XP exhibition
for a game called Ocarina of time.
And really
every time that you look at this picture,
you will find something new
that is just out of place.
Even if you're not familiar with the game,
you can probably tell there's a whole
bunch of things in here that aren't going
right. Uh, 21 hearts, 37 keys sold out.
What the heck's going on here?
And what's wonderful about this is
that this is all stuff that is achieved
within the bounds of the game.
You have a player who is going through
and manipulating a game in such a way to
make all of these crazy anomalies that
nobody would normally encounter into a
reality.
And it's the fact that you can stretch
a game to those limits that is really
exciting to a lot of people.
Next up is routing. And this is where
you put all of that information,
all of that extra work in
investigative knowledge to use.
And really what it comes down to is
trying to solve the puzzle of the game and
this code at the full
scope of start to finish,
as well as going down to much
smaller levels, the individual rooms,
the individual patterns that you're
going to need to go through in order to
reach the end solution.
And this is particularly difficult,
especially as a game has a lot
of different variables, has it,
a lot of different options that you
need to try and take into account.
There's a lot of different planning
methodologies and strategies that really
make this successful.
Uh,
one of the main ones that I tried to
work with and tell people to follow is
actually the engineering design process.
And this is one of those standard ways
that an engineer will go through looking
at a,
looking at a product that they want to
design and going through an iterative
process so that they can improve upon it,
meet the needs,
and also still satisfy
a variety of conditions.
It's kind of weird to think
about a speed run as a product,
but really it works really well
here because you're going through,
you're trying to identify a solution
set and then you're trying to make that
solution set work within
your own constraints.
This covers a similar process
to the scientific method.
The particular version of it that I've
set up here, uh, goes through identifying,
actually making sure that you know
what it is that you're trying to solve
because that can get away from you.
And a lot of times enumerating what's
possible comparing them and then
ultimately testing it and making sure
that it works within the full scope of all
the other solutions that
you've come up with.
And then finally using
that and communicating it
either in text and making a
video of it or actually
doing it in a speed run,
so that kind of enumerates the full
process and it's really important to form.
Try and follow this and identify what is
going to make a particular path fastest
and best to try and work with.
One of the other common aspects is
resource management and this is something
that a lot of people will
treat us fairly obvious,
but it becomes a really complex piece
of the puzzle when you start to have to
make trade offs and in this case
you might have an opportunity to,
let's say spend health health
is an important resource.
It's something that you can actually
trade alone in a lot of games for time.
You can try and save time
by using your health,
something that you're trying to
otherwise conserve and keep up as high as
possible to reduce risk.
In the same way you might have
other expendable resources
illustrated in this by
bombs, but you have the tradeoffs
of, well, if I keep more bombs,
how can I use those to save time later?
How much is a bomb worth in
terms of the time that it saves?
Um,
and this can be used to offset risk trying
to make let's say a boss fight easier
or a next stage, a little more
consistent, things like that. Time.
Time is also an important resource.
And this is the,
in the context of if I spend more
time now, will I save more time later?
It's all trying to make this great
weight measurement about what's actually
going to get you through optimally.
And it's a lot to keep track of,
but when you come up with
something that feels good,
it's just that much more satisfying when
you identify something that trades off
all the risk, gets you through optimally
and you're still looking at a, uh,
a good run.
You know,
resource management is really what comes
out on top as far as how you distribute
your actions.
One of the least recognize pieces of
actually planning out a speed run is
actually working with consistency and
consistency in this case is everything
that has to do with making sure that you
actually go through and succeed in the,
at the very least the worst case,
but most often the average case,
and this is just an example for this,
let's say that there's a four way stop.
You need to travel from home
and go do your groceries at the,
you can eat to go do some chores at the
bank, the grocery in the post office,
you to visit all three returned home.
The distances to all of them
is approximately the same.
How would you actually make
sure that you proceed optimally?
Assuming that you know you don't know,
let's say what the
traffic is on the roads,
you don't know the actual light pattern.
You have no guarantee that it's going
to be green when you're going to it.
So what kind of things can you do to
increase your consistency in getting
through faster? And that's a large
part of what consistency planning is.
So you can in this particular example
and start to think about, well,
if I can do a right turn on red,
so I'm going to basically skip out
on on most of the Times that I would
otherwise get stopped by only a stoplight.
Um,
if I avoid left turn so I don't have
to worry about coming oncoming traffic,
that will also increase my consistency
and actually getting through quickly.
And these are some of the other things
that you really need to think about
making it successful.
There's a,
an example in a game called Castlevania
Symphony symphony of the night that
there is a strategy that if
done successfully saves 10
to 20% off of the current
fastest time and that is
a very competitive game.
The caveat is that to
execute this successfully,
you at the very least need
a one in 4,100 chance.
Nobody has done this yet.
Nobody has even really tried.
And it's just one of those things that
even if you know something is faster,
if it's not going to ever
work out so that, um,
you're going to keep your sanity while
trying to do these attempts, then yeah,
you're probably not going
to try to incorporate it.
The last thing we want to
talk about is execution and
this has everything to do with how you're
actually able to perform in the game.
How are you able to play at a high level,
do human level optimizations
and understand how it is
that you're going to be
able to practice and reinforce these
things mentally when a lot of people are
getting started or just watching
speedruns for the first time.
They see these people doing incredible
things in these games and like, wow,
I'll never be able to do that. They're,
they're superhuman. They've got all these,
these gifts and the abilities and they're
able to complete the game so fast.
It's not something I'd be able to
do. Well at the end of the day, no,
nobody's really superhuman here.
They've just trained excessively, um,
there they didn't get their abilities
by coming into contact with radioactive
spider. That it's much more
along the lines of, uh,
they've put in a whole lot of work.
They've done the training,
they've done all of the practice necessary
to actually reinforce these things
that they're doing.
And then to really cut down on
the overhead of their own actions.
And for that purpose,
the,
it's much more like trying to be a Ninja
and you're trying be an average person,
uh, who just happens to be very trained
in a particular thing and do particularly
well.
And this is something,
there's a lot of strategies is to actually
do this starting first and foremost
with practice. And really what
we're talking about when Prek,
we mentioned practice is
you're trying to learn.
Practice is all about trying
to learn how your body works.
Trying to learn how he, uh, you're
going to respond in certain situations.
Making that,
uh,
really into an automatic mechanism so
that when you come across something,
you don't think about it, you just do
it. And there's a lot of different, uh,
pieces of psychology
that are important here.
Trying to set up appropriate
chunking strategies,
trying to work with scaffolding,
um,
and there's many different aspects to
trying to train effectively so that that
training isn't lost so that,
uh, you actually improve faster.
And it really is just about
understanding your own brain.
But even beyond that,
once you have the practice in,
once you've built up the muscle memory,
there's a lot of things that you really
need to do to rely on the game to
synchronize up those actions. And this
is where, where various cues come in.
So you're looking for things in the game,
things that you generate
yourself or just get a feel for,
to actually set up your actions so that
they actually work within the realm of
what you need to do.
Um,
there's a lot of good examples for
this in super Metroid where, uh,
just by complete chance, uh, the,
there are plants, foreground objects,
other things that you can look for that
you can use to identify where I need to
execute a particular move,
where you need to jump off a wall and
get up to somewhere that you're not
supposed to.
All sorts of things like this that you
can rely on to help you sync up what
you're doing. Um, in there's a, another
example with Mike Tyson's punch out where,
uh,
the developers actually made a dynamic
audience in the background that otherwise
doesn't do a whole lot and you're,
you're primarily focused on the fighter.
But while the fighters
are doing certain things,
they included cues in that audience
that help you to identify when you're
actually supposed to start up a counter
attack when you're supposed to do a
dodge. Some of these examples that are
pretty hard to see in this particular, uh,
pictures.
But there's a guy flashing a camera at
a particular point that you're supposed
to counter attack.
There's another one who drops his glasses.
And all of these little extra details
that the developer is actually included
really help out in trying to identify
how you're going to counter these
otherwise difficult threats.
But even beyond visual things,
audio is really important and this is
important not only from a reaction speed
standpoint,
you can actually respond to audio about
a 20 to 40 milliseconds faster than you
can visual cues. But it's also just
really important in terms of knowing,
let's say I'm in a boss area,
that boss is going to spawn
at a particular time and
the music just so happens
to be synced up with that and this
case, uh, in a game called [inaudible],
which I run,
um,
where you're using a particular part of
that intro sound sequence to know when
to start to launch your attack so that
you can get a very powerful attack in
right at the beginning
when he's first coming out.
One of the last things that I
really want to discuss is that
what you're doing is a performance.
It's a complete execution of your route.
And as part of that, you also
have instances where you're
getting into your mind,
where you are starting to doubt yourself,
where you're just trying to actually
keep up with a high level of plays you're
going through and what's actually showing.
Along the bottom there is a heartbreak
graph of this is my heart going through a
speed or in a spike of Sky Blazer, which
is the first game out of a speed run.
And each of those instances
as you're going through,
you can see that it gradually increases
and I'm just sitting down. Uh,
this gets up to the point of moderate
exercise all while I'm in a chair just
because I'm trying to
rectify whatever's going on with the
screen and keep up my composure so that I
can continue to perform optimally.
And that's really another thing that
comes in with a conditioning trying to do
these runs over and over
again. You identify, um,
here's my best strategy for
trying to calm down. Here's how I,
I don't start to mess up simply because
I've put too much effort and thought
into what's going on in the
screen. And it, you know, it's,
it's a significant part of it when you're
going through and your heart's racing,
you've got the adrenaline
pumping, all that. Um,
but it's another really
fun part of a speed run.
If you're able to get through the end,
you get a great release.
It's just feels amazing.
Even if you drop a run right at the end,
it can still feel really rewarding that
you've done so well in that, you know,
I can get there again.
So that covers the overall process here
is just a dump of a whole bunch of other
topics that kind of fit into
these general parts of the phases.
And really what I just wanted to show
here is that what I've talked about today
is just scratching the surface.
There's so much to optimization
to planning to proper
presentation of facts and
details about games that really
there's something for everyone,
even if you're not intent on trying to
go for a world record or anything like
that.
Like you can enjoy the routing process
coming up with a solution you can enjoy
breaking apart a game,
finding out what makes it tick.
And then exploiting those boundaries
and taking it to something further and
still you can enjoy the practice
properties, improving yourself,
coming up with a real product
that shows iterative improvement.
So just to wrap up everything
related to the speed run process,
really my main recommendation
is if you're getting started,
even if you're already a conditioned
runner, really you want to try every step,
try every bit of the phases a, even if
it's a game that's been done to death,
just so you know what you enjoy.
You can find all sorts of
things as well as improve,
own understanding of what you're doing
and an and increase your enjoyment on top
of that. And really to get the
most satisfaction about this,
you want to be trying to push yourself,
um,
don't necessarily just shoot
for a record because it's there.
You really have to make it something that
is worth the effort that you put into
it and something that you can
be proud of after the fact,
beyond simply being the
top of the leaderboard.
And also never forget that
you have a great opportunity
here to work with others.
There's a very supportive community
all around who's willing to help,
who's railing to support and just watch
your runs and something to be, uh,
it feels great to be a part of.
I want to end out with just a quick
discussion of where speed running actually
is today. Uh, as a practice.
It really is something that's only blown
up within the last 10 years or so. Uh,
this particular chart is showing the
total amounts raised and the average
viewership of what are known as the
Games done quick events and these are um,
twice annual events that
are entirely speed focus,
but there are benefiting in
particular charity at each event.
And it's something that has really
kind of exploded in popularity,
but it mimics the growth and attention
that's been given to speed runs as it's
going through. If this graph
included this year is our a numbers,
we'd also see the trend continuing
and it's one of the things that's most
rewarding to me is that this is a hobby
with video games that's actually making
a difference in the world.
Uh,
we raised millions of dollars simply
because people enjoy watching it.
And are particularly generous with, uh,
appreciating the skills going into it.
And that's something that I honestly
find particularly wonderful and, um,
is really rewarding beyond just
doing the speed runs itself.
And that kind of wraps up everything.
Um,
everything that we've talked about today
is a subset of some of the topics that
I address in a book that I've been
working on for quite a long time now, uh,
called speed run science and it tries to
break down every little bit of it. Um,
in addition to discussing
the actual, uh, process,
it goes into the philosophy,
some of the history of how it
actually evolved and became
more important. And, um,
finally it'll, it'll be available in,
in just a few weeks for preorder, um,
probably, uh, arriving at people's
doors somewhere around February.
A special thanks to carry fry who's
by illustrator for the book. Um,
she provided many of the illustrations
that you're seeing throughout the slide,
the slide deck as well. And um, uh,
Tony [inaudible] who is my layout editor
for also produced a number of these
graphics.
Uh,
so a special thanks to them and the
rest of the fan game or crew for working
with me and the production of this
book. With that, I'll close it out.
You can reach out to me at any of those,
uh,
social media or mail addresses
at the bottom and without,
I'm happy to take any questions.
Uh, so I had some questions from people
who, uh, are in the office right now.
First Save the, Oh, she's no. Uh,
and second, uh, question from Iowa.
What's the weirdest way you've
seen someone discover a trick?
The weirdest way. Oh Man. So there's a,
a particular game called dragon view
on Super Nintendo and this game,
oh my, a friend of mine was working
on the speed run for this game.
And at a particular part we discovered
a bug that had not prior been known.
And the only way that you execute this
bug is simply that you haven't turned off
the game.
So after completing a certain
story element and then
you reach another story on
it and you were expected to,
um,
take a break somewhere in the middle and
you'd never would have seen this happen,
but they have left some
dirty memory somewhere.
And what actually ends up
happening is a huge, oh my,
it's a very scary bug. Um, you basically,
it allows you to overwrite the entire
memory contents, even going up,
tries to start fiddling with RAAM. Um,
it does a lot of very interesting things,
but this was discovered completely by
accident simply because they were trying
to go through the game all in one sitting.
And it actually turns out that
if you get the exact magic, um,
conditions,
you can make this work you into the ending
credits so that you can effectively,
uh, you have a choice between if you
try to play it completely like this,
you either completely crashed the
game, um, or you make it to the end.
And it was just a really interesting find.
Um,
uh,
if you want details I can describe that
after the afterwards a little bit more
about what's actually
going on under the hood.
I think I saw a speed run for a life to
that word by saving and reloading the
game such that when you reload the game,
you're in a different position and the
video for those run where edited so you
can only see the game play.
Is that something that's a
specific category as you mentioned,
the categories before?
Uh, that would be a segmented
run for the most part,
especially if they're removing
kind of the in between. Um,
but it really is up to how the community
just fines what is challenging,
what you're actually trying
to show. Um, and in this case,
let's say that the half life to simply
by saving and quitting is what actually
alters your, your position. Then
that's something that you can use in a,
what's called a single segment run
and done in one sitting. But, um,
most often for those kinds of things,
uh,
it's going to be segmented
in that you do a block of it,
tried to get it as optimal as possible.
In that Save,
you're going to bring it up
again and do another one. Um,
whether or not it's allowed or
expected is really up to the game,
and it really depends on how the game
interacts with those saves. All right.
Thank you so much for coming today.
It's my pleasure to talk
[inaudible].